hello everyone and welcome to this
fantastic video on what is LinkedIn on
the simply done YouTube channel all of
you must be already aware of blockchain
but let me give you a quick refresher a
blockchain is a digital Ledger that
store information like a digital
database without a central Authority
controlling it instead a blockchain is
maintained by a network of computers
each one is storing a copy of The Ledger
when a new transaction is added to the
Ledger the network has to approve it
before it can be recorded other side
langchin is like a blockchain but with a
few differences unlike a blockchain
which stores information about financial
transaction Lang chain can store any
kind of data or information like medical
records supply chain data or even social
media profiles line change design also
allows for private transaction where
only a certain people can access and
view the store data which differs from a
regular blockchain sounds fascinating
right well it is and there is a lot more
to learn and discuss about blockchain
technology and this video so stay tuned
till the very end as we embark on this
amazing journey of exploring luncheon
according to recent studies Ai and
machine learning related job posting
have increased by 344 percent in the
past five years companies across the
globe are actively seeking professional
who can harness the power of data and
build intelligent system the average
salary is 150 000 in the US and 15 lakhs
in India as the field evolves new job
titles and responsibilities are
anticipated to cater to Industry
requirements prominent companies like
Microsoft Google Amazon IBM Goldman
search and apple are actively recruiting
machine learning Engineers hey everyone
welcome to simple learns YouTube channel
but before we dive into that don't
forget to subscribe like and share there
is no better time to train yourself in
the exciting field of machine learning
if you are looking for a course that
covers everything from the fundamentals
to Advanced Techniques for that
accelerate your career in Ai and ml with
our comprehensive postgraduate program
in Ai and machine learning gain
expertise in machine learning deep
learning NLP computer vision and
reinforcement learning you will receive
a prestigious certificate exclusive
alumni membership and ask me anything
session by IBM with three Capstone and
25 plus industry project using real data
sets from Twitter Uber and many more you
will gain practical experience master
classes by Caltech faculty and IBM
expert and no top-notch education
simply and job as it help you to get
noticed by Leading companies these
programs covers statistics python
supervised and unsupervised learning NLP
neural network contributions Gans Keras
tensorflow and many more skills so
enroll now and unlock exciting Ai and ml
opportunities the link is in the
description box below so without any
further adolay let's get started so what
is Lang chain
is a versatile open source framework
that empowers AI developers to integrate
large language model llms such as GPT 4
with the external data available in the
python or JavaScript packages land chain
addresses the limitation of GPT models
trained only up until 2021. while gpt4
models exhibit impressive general
knowledge their potential is greatly
enhanced by connecting them to
customized data and customize
computations and this is precisely what
Lang chain facility
by enabling alarms access comprehensive
database line chain empowers them to
generate responses based on the most
up-to-date information found in the
reports documents and website content
since the launch of GTP 4 in March
Langston has garnered substantially
popularity due to its flexibility and
the my rate of possibilities it unlocks
when combined with the high powered llm
so moving forward let's see why we need
Lang chin so Langston represents a
practical solution to overcome this
limitation through a practical approach
it involves pre-processing the tax
Corpus by dividing it into manageable
chunks or summaries emitting them in a
vector space and subsequently searching
for similar chunks when a question is
paused so this methodology of
pre-processing real time and data
collection and interaction with the llm
is not only applicable in the context
but also extend to other scenarios such
as code semantic search
simplifies the composition of these
components by offering an abstraction
the simplification of the process often
called prompt Plumbing plays a crucial
role and will grow in significance as
alignments becomes more powerful and
necess that the provision of additional
data during the prompt execution so
moving forward let's see how does
luncheon work so line chain simplifies
the process of organizing large volume
of data that can be easily accessed by
the llm requiring minimal computational
power it operates by taking a
subsequential data source like 50 page
PDF and breaking it down into manageable
chunks and that are embedded into a
vector store so with the vectorized
representation of the extensive document
at hand we can combine them with the llm
to selectively retrieve the necessary
information for creating prompt
completion pairs
so when we input a prompt into our
chatbot equipped with luncheon it
queries the vector store to find
partition information a kind of
miniature Google tailored to your
document once the relevant details are
obtained they are combined with the llm
prompt and fed into the llm to generate
our desired response after that
integration of line chain with the open
as llms also enables the creation of
application capable of taking action
such as web serving email sending and
other tasks related to API and at the
end you will get a reply so this is how
Lang chain works with open ai's llms
moving forward let's see some use cases
of luncheon so there is a wide range of
potential application for Lang chain
here are few examples so first one is
personal AI email assistant luncheon can
be used to develop an intelligent email
assistant that understood and generates
responses based on the user's
preferences and writing style the second
one is AI study buddy so Langston can
assist a student in their Studies by
providing real-time access to relevant
research papers textbooks and
educational resources offering
personalized study recommendation and
answering theoretical questions
and the third one is AI data analytics
Langston can be employed to enhance data
analytics by allowing large language
model to access and analyze wash amount
of structure and unstructured data
enabling more comprehensive insight and
prediction and the fourth one is custom
company customer service chatbot
Langston can power chatbot that provide
tailored customer service experience by
integrating up-to-date company
information product knowledge and the
customer data to offer personalized and
accurate responses and the fifth one is
social media content creation
so line chain can help content creator
generate engaging and relevant social
media content by leveraging its ability
to access the latest information Trends
and insights from various sources so
these example illustrate just the
fraction of the potential application
for luncheon and its versatility extend
to a wide array of other scenarios as
well so after seeing use cases of
LinkedIn let's move forward and see
using open AI how line chain works or
not so welcome to the demo part so here
first we will set up the what the
problem is using the chargpt
so this is the chat GPT this is
something that we all know and I'm going
to first ask chargpt what is Line train
and we will see what it will say okay so
here I will write what
okay what
chain
so as you can see it is saying I'm sorry
but as of my knowledge cut off in
September 2021 I'm not familiar with the
term Lang chin it is possible that it
could be a term or concept that immersed
or became popular at that time
and could you provide more context or
details about what you are referring to
that way I can try to assist you better
so as you can see why this has happened
it is because Langston is a more recent
Library
so this is the new library and land
chain is I think published in uh
somewhere around January and it is new
and chat gbt has not been drained on the
data more recent than I think like
around 2021 as you can see it is written
here September 2021 okay so this is the
problem number one
so let's see the problem number two
so here I will write
hey
chat
CPT
tell me
how many
meetings
my things are plugged
today
calendar
again it is saying I'm sorry but as an
AI language model I don't have access to
personal data about individuals unless
it has been shared with me during our
conversation I can browse or retrieve
information from your Google calendar or
any other personal documents or accounts
however if you have access to your
Google calendar you can easily check the
number of meetings blocked today by
opening your calendar and looking at the
schedule events for the day the calendar
interfaces should display the number of
meetings or events you have scheduled
and why this is happening because we are
using chat GPT open AI okay
but if we will use
API of open AI
okay currently I am using the chargpt
but if we will use the open AI API so we
can connect to our
Google Drive Google
calendar and and anything
after that we can easily retrieve our
information
okay so this is well so as you can see
using this image what Lang chain does
okay is it is going to connect your AI
models okay these are the AI models open
AI hugging phases
so what the language does okay using
llms
it is going to connect
to outside sources like Google drive or
Wikipedia wall frame or you know Google
Calendar anything
to the outside sources
and you can do some really cool things
without those outside sources okay you
can ask to the chat GPT and or you can
make your own model llm model but
without llm model and Langston you can't
connect with the outside resources
okay
so all of a sudden you can start to
chain together commands Okay that is why
the length chain is used chain okay
these are the llm models open air
hugging faces and you can change both of
them using Lang chain okay you can
change the outside sources and this llms
using Lang chain
okay
after chaining llm and outside sources
using line chain you can ask any
question to them
okay what is my how many documents I
wrote in the last year and this one or
you can say hey Charity what's the
weather today to open AI or anything
you can ask these kind of questions
and the application for the luncheon are
the endless and we have already seen
some of them
okay so now let's see the documentation
part of the luncheon official documented
placement part of the luncheon
so as you can see this is the official
documentation of the Lang chain
okay so here as you can see what is the
length and Legion is a framework for
developing application power added
language models I learned models it
enables applications that are data where
originally
so as you can see there are the certain
modules and the example use cases as you
can see the chat Bots
and you can create the multi uh you know
chat Bots using allo lamps like open Ai
and there are many things like
interaction with apis autonomas
okay you can check anything
these are some of the modules of the
line change language and provide the
standard extendable interfaces okay so
these are the modules and these are the
use cases
okay ecosystems and the support API
references these are the API references
how you can use the API and as you can
see this is the installation part using
pip you can use
install the legend and the conda part is
here the content start okay so this is
this you know official document you can
go through it and you will learn you
will definitely learn something if you
will go through
the official document
so that's all we had for this video we
can call it a wrap now if you have still
any question or doubt let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will help you at the earliest so
thank you so much for being here today
we'll see you next time until then stay
safe and keep learning with simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign